zdf mit dem zweiten sehe ich nur die
hälfte
nachdem ich es beschreiben gerstenkorn
hab ich übrigens immer zwei wochen
praktisch die gibt es übrigens in lugano
besser
ich gehe jetzt übrigens was frühstück
mit shady
folge sind sich diese beste meist besser
kannst du mich bitte auch mal vergessen
mehr richtig trinken sie war ganz normal
hübsches mädchen kam uns entgegen und
ich wollte mich eigentlich um geräten
weil wir noch ein paar andere leute
waren wurden
ich habe mal standen auch so einfach
soll das verbergen einfach steigenberger
war für mich auch nicht ich kann voll
verlernt zu filmen was gießen dass ich
durch mein bild das wäre denn ein
warum stehen wir jetzt eigentlich so ein
drogen laden ich habe letztens schon
mindesten wir angeschrieben mit
und dann geht so wollen bin ich wollte
mich in diesem land ich komme aus
hamburg ich kenne mich ja nicht sagen
dass ich jetzt schon mal dass ein bier
angeschrieben habe auf insider mit einer
auch model die allerdings alle nicht
geantwortet weil die auch kein deutsch
spricht ja mal meister klar ich probiere
jetzt mal glück beim miss germany 2018
also ihr hier im schnitt sie hatten zwei
affen zwar nicht geantwortet weil das
ist ein cooler schottisch glauben ich
bin jetzt wieder zu hause mit jetzt ist
auch dass man auch echt mega gut managt
nämlich das rote hier von dem biber mit
diesem boot wir hier mit diesem ding
hier eigentlich auch absolut niemanden
was hier mensch wenigstens management
beim outfit lassen im gegensatz zu
meiner trainerkarriere
speziell für sie jetzt online beratung
via asset manager partie bestimmt nur
für mich sagt bist du den 15 ich liebe
mein leben
weißt du was nicht gerade erfahren dass
sechs freunde zu mir kommen sollte war
da so ein vogel drauf sind und das ist
auch die bildungsstand irgendwie sind
alle meine freunde gerade in köln ich
weiß auch nicht warum das hier zum
beispiel das ding ist halte ich will die
eigentlich sehen aber meine augen aus
boden wie soll man das auge aus und ich
kann nicht ganz sagt die augen zumachen
gehe ich dahin und nicht dass wir uns
von den bauern schon in hamburg im
letzten block bei mir dabei jetzt ist er
noch können
übernimmt das alles jetzt einzigartige
wunderschöne ja nix bis 4 grad
[Musik]
harry und carola das motto des abends
richtung dichtung
[Musik]
ja und ich habe dir heut rose
mitgebracht
[Musik]
na ist wm-zweiter bürger von fünf
stunden hier sind ganz schön enttäuscht
der flug bestätigte ein sprecher
nein wohl nicht geworden
sympathisch
[Musik]
wir sind jetzt auf einer hausparty
gelandet und das spiel zu zweit wir
kommen mit einem becher entschuldige ich
mich für die jegliche aufnahmen die
gestern mit meiner kamera gemacht wurden
ich habe keine ahnung was gestern ab
ging ich weiß auch immer noch doch sind
aber besser oder will ich das erzähle
eigentlich von briefen oder nach
beschlüssen
ich finde es hat gar nicht viel über den
charakter eines menschen aus mein plan
für heute ist auf jeden fall dass ich
gleich den kompletten kleiderschrank
hier ausräumen und das t shirt ist mir
deutlich zu groß ich habe auf jeden fall
gleich diesen ganzen schwachsinn raus
packs in diese tasche das wird er
niemals alles reinpassen vergleicht mehr
von sander noch ein paar aldi tüten
allerdings war ich dann heute wieder
nach hamburg
los geht's mit egrifta welche behandlung
so die ganzen vollidioten sind weg und
das sind meist aus meinem kleiderschrank
habe ich jetzt aufgeräumt
beziehungsweise ausgeräumt in diese
ganzen sachen da rein
ich habe keinen plan b das ist mein auto
passen sollte kaffee ziemlich voll
geladen aber läuft unter meinem letzten
blog denkt einfach 674 leute dass meine
neue wohnung aussieht wie eine
zahnarztpraxis ich bin nämlich nicht in
hamburg sondern auch pause irgendwo am
arsch der welt und hat mir 22 mal
spaghetti oder bestellt und mit cola
weil ich echt müde war fehlt ihr das
nach vorne leute mit laser hatte gerade
eine verkehrskontrolle ich dachte erst
was mache ich denn falsch und dann
fahren die sollen mir vorbei und fahren
direkt vor mir bitte folgen haben
nämlich angehalten und das waren zwei
ganz junge polizistin und die bahn
richtig freundlich also jetzt bei diesem
ganzen polizei gehasste gerade mal
komplett entgegengewirkt die waren
richtig freundlich und man sollte da
echt nicht perfekt jetzt sitze ich im
dunkeln
man sollte ich nicht sagen alle
polizisten sind scheiße und ja ich weiss
polizeigewalt ist real und es findet
statt und es ist kacke aber die waren
gerade so was von freundlich und habe
mir alles erklärt so bitte nicht nervös
aber ich war halt wirklich am zittern
der mir dass man auf jeden fall ganz
liebe erklärt meinte hey dass eine
allgemeine verkehrskontrolle es macht
mir heute schon den ganzen abend bei
einigen leuten
wir bräuchten wir dann einmal
führerschein und fahrzeugpapiere bitte
ich natürlich komplett nervös der erst
mal meine erste fc köln mitgliedskarte
gegeben
ich kann so was und dann wurde es auf
einmal so ein richtiges auto quiz den
die wissen wo mein warndreieck und
verbandskasten ist und auf jeden fall
die 19 jahren auch noch schöne
weiterfahrt wo geht es denn nicht sehr
nach hamburg
hoffentlich begegnen sollte nicht noch
mal kennt ihr das gemacht nichts falsch
aber denkt euch sowohl das mache ich
ganz falsch und so voll nervös
wir sehen uns in hamburg wieder ich
hatte einfach eine polizeikontrolle
ich hab mit der polizei zu tun wie ein
richtiger gangster hamburg 187 enormen
platz sagt bescheid
naja ich bin auf jeden fall heute mit
einem blauen auge davon gekommen und das
ist lustig gerade weil ich habe ein
blaues auge auf jeden fall weil es jetzt
echt noch mal so ein knüller haben
abenteuer ahlmann des vertrauens das
geil ist übrigens dass sich mittlerweile
auch vorher mit meiner wohnung habe also
das sind jetzt nicht vorher dass es nur
1 vorn aber im wohnzimmer sind auch
welche ich lieg aber am bett ich zeige
euch das im nächsten blog
[Musik]
[Applaus]